That all we're going to say about Model
Based Reinforcement Learning in POMDPs
and now we're going to talk a little bit
about Model Free Reinforcement Learning
in POMDPS.
>> Okay.
>> And
particular we're going to focus
on memory loss policies and
what I'd like to show actually is not so
much about learning, but
more about planning.
So here's a little POMDP.
This is a POMDP that has
four underlying states.
Two observations there's this
sort of clear blue thing and
there's a green thing.
Two actions, black and red.
Black takes you to the right and
red takes you to the left
back around the other way.
And the way that this is set up, I think
of it as a one dimensional hallway.
And we don't know exactly
where we are in the hallway.
But we're trying to get to you know
say my office along the hallway.
If we're to the left of my hallway,
we should go right to go to my office.
But if we just keep going left and
left and left and left and
left we're just going to go and get
stuck and It's infinitely long hallway,
it feels like an infinitely long.
We just going to get stuck at the end.
Whereas if we're to the right of
my office and we go to the right,
we also kind of get stuck, we need to go
to the left to get where we're going.
Once we actually get to the office,
we have a reset action, the black action
resets us with equal probability
to one of those three states.
because I don't know we're drunk and
then we get to go again try
to get back to the office.
>> Okay, good.
>> First, I want to point out.
I think we talked about an example
just like this before and
we said that probably the right thing
to do is to go like left, right,
right, that sort of thing.
Because each time we reset we're in one
of these states which we go left hoping
that it's going to take us out of here,
but that doesn't seem to work so
we go right to take us
from this side back out.
Actually right, right,
left is probably even better.
Just keep doing this over and
over and over again.
All right.
But now what we're talking about
are memoryless policies.
So memoryless policy has the form.
When you're in the green state.
Well, there's only one action choice so
you take it.
When you're in the clear blue state.
You have to go either left or right.
Or maybe you can choose
probabilistically among left and right.
But you can't do these sequences
because it's memoryless.
[SOUND] You need memory
to do a sequence.
>> Right, that's a problem.
Okay I see, I see why this is a problem
or you could just invent memory.
>> POMPDP's do invent memory.
If you're going to learn
the POMDP model of this,
it captures the memory that you need
to actually make optimal decisions.
>> All right, fair enough.